encore un attentat à proximité d'un
poste français en fin d'après-midi un
parachutiste français tués et une
douzaine de blessés huit libanais tué
par ailleurs yasser arafat est attendu
ce soir en egypte les comptes d'elf
aquitaine et les avions renifleurs le
secrétaire d'état au budget accuse un
ancien président de la cour des comptes
de forfaiture pour avoir détruit le
rapport de la cour des comptes sur
l'opération conseil des ministres ce
matin le ministre de l'éducation
nationale propose aux protagonistes de
nouvelles négociations bilatérales sur
la question de l'enseignement privé
un corps repêchés dans la seine à paris
celui de l'homme d'affaires britannique
disparu il ya trois semaines en même
temps qu'un autre britannique retrouvée
lui
moyer a breath madame monsieur bonsoir
un camion piégé a donc explosé cet après
midi en plein centre de beyrouth
tout près du quartier général du
contingent français de la force
multinationale il y à un mort et une
douzaine de blessés côté français huit
morts libanais tout de suite sur place
des précisions avec notre envoyé spécial
jacquat bouchard jacques vous m'entendez
alors que sait-on ce soir sur les
circonstances exactes de cet attentat il
a écouté d'un camion d'un camion était
bourré explosé son chauffeur a garé à
proximité du siège du
3e rpima régiment français d'intenses
crise marine de la force multinationale
et le chauffeur a eu le temps de prendre
la fuite
quelques instants avant l'explosion qui
a été énorme
vous donnez un premier bilan de 14
blessés pour l'instant et un mort du
côté français et les dernières
estimations du côté libanais sont de 10
morts morts et 27 blessés
alors il ya eu peu de témoin c'était en
fin d'après midi et il semble que le
fait que du camion contre un muret de
protection à faire un film en plus
sérieuse
les france avait renforcé ses positions
comme ils ont tendance à l'emporter la
plupart des positions militaires
françaises dans beyrouth depuis la
succession d'attentats qui ont eu lieu
récemment
ce qui a permis de le croire d'éviter
une véritable et quatre ans et est ce
qu'on est sûr ce soir à beyrouth que cet
attentat visait bien le peut ce français
alors écoutez j'ai rencontré le colonel
roudeillac le le chef de corps le
responsable du 3e rpima est un peu près
une demi heure après l'explosion
effectivement le plein elle n'excluait
pas la possibilité que ce soit un autre
objectif qui était visé il nous parlait
d'un poste des palanges ici parce que
nous étions nous sembla en secteur
crédit du secteur et ya et il y aurait
une permanence phalangistes non loin de
l'explosion il ya également une caserne
de l'armée libanaise mais écoutez
néanmoins on peut néanmoins imaginer que
les français étaient plus
particulièrement visés car le camion a
perdu d'exemple un mur de protection qui
protège et avant tout parce qu'en
français et le pc du 3e rpima se
trouvait à 25 mètres seulement du lieu
de l'attentât
merci jacques à bouchard au ministère de
la défense à paris on indique ce soir
que on n'est pas encore certain que
l'attentât visait réellement le poste
français ce matin déjà
un poste un autre poste militaire
français avait été attaqué à la roquette
et à l'armé automatique mais là les
importantes mesures de sécurité prises
depuis le dramatique attentat d'octobre
dernier ont empêché qu'il y ait des
victimes
un autre attentat à beyrouth ouest cet
après midi a fait quatre morts et une
douzaine de blessés dans un bar et
quelques instants plus tard une
patrouille de marines américains essuyé
des tirs près de l'ambassade des états
unis
cette recrudescence des attentats à
beyrouth coïncide avec l'évacuation des
palestiniens de tripoli opéré hier au
profit de la syrie et des dissidents de
l'olp et elle coïncide aussi avec les
dernières déclarations de washington et
de rome
concernant le sort de leur contingent
hier soir le président reagan a affirmé
que ses troupes ne quitterait pas le
liban tant que les objectifs de la force
multinationale n'ont pas été atteints
rassurant ainsi les milieux politiques
libanais
de son côté le gouvernement italien a
annoncé hier soir son intention de
réduire graduellement son contingent au
liban qui est en ce moment le plus
important des quatre composantes de la
force multinationale de rome victor
vraiment donc et dans un premier temps
on va retirer 1000 militaires italiens
sur les 2100 qui se trouvent à beyrouth
et on va rappeler en priorité les
appelés du contingent qui constituent la
grande majorité de la force italienne la
télévision italienne a abondamment
montré en son temps les images des
attentats contre les forces françaises
et américaines
et on peut dire que la possibilité d'un
retrait du contingent italien a commencé
à être évoquée après que les français
les américains aient décidé
d'entreprendre les opérations de guerre
de représailles contre les auteurs de
ces attentats
les italiens se sont dit et si ça nous
arrivait à nous aussi
et si nous aussi nous étions obligées de
riposter donc refus d'être entraîné dans
un engrenage dans une escalade
même s'il est vrai que le contingent
italien n'a subi qu'un attentat minimes
qui a fait un mort et quelques blessés
le contingent italien a pris position
autour et à l'intérieur du camp de sabra
et chatila tant qu'il s'agit de protéger
les populations civiles et d'éviter les
massacres tout va bien mais s'il est
vrai que la force multinationale doit
également assurer l'autorité du
président gemayel surtout le liban alors
là et du côté italien on considère que
cette mission a été un échec total
conclusion il y a plus à perdre qu'à
gagner dans cette présence au liban mais
le retrait sera progressive pour ne pas
heurter trop brutalement les français
les américains
l'aviation israélienne a bombardé ce
matin près de baalbeck dans la plaine
ibanez la même zone que celle qui avait
visé les avions français le 17 novembre
dernier une zone contrôlée par des
chiites libanais pro iranien
le raid israélien coïncide avec le
sursaut d'indignation que l'on constate
en israël au lendemain de l'évacuation
des palestiniens de tripoli devant les
députés israéliens le premier ministre
et le ministre de la défense se sont
dits indignés par l'assistance prêtée à
l'opération par la france et la grèce
ils ont expliqué qu'israël s'était
refusé à intervenir militairement pour
éviter un affrontement avec des
puissants amis c'est l'expression
employée
le ministre de la défense israélien a
répété qu'israël continuerait de se
battre sur tous les fronts contre le
terrorisme et ce soir l'ambassadeur
d'israël en france dénonce le rôle de la
france qui sera dorénavant responsable
des actes de l'ol paie at il dit quant
aux cinq bateau grec transportant les
quatre mille palestiniens de yasser
arafat
ils poursuivent leur route en ordre
dispersé tantôt vers l'afrique du nord
tantôt vers l'egypte yasser arafat est
attendu ce soir à port saïd nous envoyés
spéciaux philippe rochot et frédéric
vasseur ont fait une partie du voyage
avec lui
pour monter sur le bateau d'arafat ce
fut une véritable panique tous les
combattants voulait accompagner le chef
de l'olp et avec leur famille résultat
1500 personnes se sont retrouvées à bord
alors qu'il ne pouvait en contenir qu'un
millier après six heures d'attentes et
d'incertitudes l'odyssée le bateau
transportant le chef de l'olp et quitter
tripoli
escorté par les navires de guerre
français et battant pavillon des nations
unies aucun incident pas d'avions
israéliens dans le ciel la sortie
d'arafat de tripoli restera une
opération réussie
ces hommes et leurs familles avaient
tous fui l'avancée des forces syriennes
et de leurs alliés pour se replier sur
tripoli
il n'en porte en général qu'une valise
avec eux et une couverture pour certains
c'est le troisième épisode après des
batailles comme amman en jordanie en 70
déroutant 80 depuis tripoli en 81 points
en quelques heures puis se sont
retrouvés dans une atmosphère de
croisière avec la télévision mais le
coeur n'y était pas des familles ont
emporté le souvenir de leurs morts comme
cette femme dont le frère a été tué à
beyrouth l'an passé jamila explique
qu'elle est libanaise mais son destin
est lié à celui des palestiniens
marié un combattant de l'ol paie elle le
suit partout avec ses deux enfants
et cette fois son exode sera le yémen du
sud
mais jamais sur le bateau arafat est
particulièrement détendu il s'en va mais
il estime qu'il sort de tripoli la tête
haute et les combattants viennent le
féliciter une nouvelle fois il a sauvé
nous distille l'indépendance de
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine quand nous lui demandons s'il
se sent en sécurité encadrée par les
navires de guerre français il est fier
de l'événement imaginer dit-il que je
pars de tripoli sous escorte française
avec le pavillon des nations unies n'est
ce pas incroyable
je suis là
ce fut pourtant un voyage sans bavure
sur une mer des plus calmes les
combattants avaient été désarmées avant
de monter à bord et un air de paix
régnait sur ce bateau signalons encore
pour en finir ce soir avec ce lourd
dossier du proche orient que la turquie
est à son tour frappé par une série
d'attentats deux explosions à la même
heure ce matin à ankara et à istanbul où
quatre passants ont été blessés des
attentats liés à la guerre au
moyen-orient selon le premier ministre
turc
plusieurs ressortissants étrangers ont
été arrêtés ce soir venons en maintenant
à l' affaire qui fait grand bruit dans
le monde politique français
la sphère des avions renifleurs d'elf
aquitaine que nos confrères du canard
enchaîné exhume dans leur numéro
d'aujourd'hui nous vous l'expliquons dès
hier soir
il s'agit des méthodes de financement
utilisées par la société pétrolière pour
couvrir les frais d'une nouvelle méthode
d'exploration il s'agit plus encore de
la manière dont un ancien président de
la cour des comptes bernard bec qui
était jusqu'à octobre 82 à la tête de la
plus haute juridiction de contrôle des
finances publiques de la manière donc
dont monsieur beck a traité le dossier
cet après midi à l'assemblée nationale
le secrétaire d'état au budget henri
emmanuelli l'a directement mise en cause
en l'accusant d'avoir commis un acte de
forfaiture
jean-louis le sel j'ai sous les yeux en
ce moment même le document manuscrit que
monsieur beck a écrit et dans lequel il
retrace l'histoire mouvementée de ces
rapports deux exemplaires avaient été
remis par lui-même à monsieur raymond
barre alors premier ministre en janvier
je suis en mesure d'affirmer sans craint
d'être démentie qu'aucun de ces deux
rapports ne figure dans les archives de
l'état
quant au très petit nombre d'exemplaires
qui restait y compris d'ailleurs le
brouillon du rapport
monsieur bec les détenait
personnellement dans son coffre à la
première présidence
ce sont ces exemplaires qui reconnaît
lui même avoir détruit par lacérations
je rappelle que cette action que je
n'hésite pas à qualifier de forfaiture
s'est déroulé à la fin de novembre 1982
le rapport
dans cette troisième enquête que j'ai
reçus le 18 octobre rapporte que le
capter sur les tenants et les
aboutissants de cette affaire
il confirme choléra a transféré ensuite
un total de 100 milliards d'anciens
francs au profit de sociétés
immatriculées à panama lichenstein aux
nouvelles hébrides et qu'une partie
seulement de ces sommes a pu être
récupérée lorsqu'il s'avère en 1979 qui
ne s'agissait que d'une gigantesque
escroquerie au mieux en revanche au
niveau trouve guère de précisions sur
les conditions dans lesquelles
l'opération s'est déjà engagée ni bien
entendu sur la destination finale réel
des sommes transférées en suisse sur
laquelle je ne possède aucune
information le terme de forfaiture
employé par le ministre à l'encontre de
monsieur baic vise selon l'article 166
du code pénal tout crime commis par un
fonctionnaire public dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
hormis les cas où la justice prononce
des peines plus grave pour des actes
connexes comme la corruption
la peine encourue est la dégradation
civique
patricia charnolé revient maintenant
plus en détail sur cette affaire des
avions renifleurs une affaire
rocambolesque dit au gouvernement mais
néanmoins très grave
de fait au moins en témoigne
premièrement une société nationale elf
aquitaine a dépensé à perte des
centaines de millions de francs
deuxièmement un rapport officiel émanant
de la cour des comptes aurait été
détruit c'est là un cas sans précédent
dans l'histoire de cette vénérable
institution
tout commence en 1978 elf aquitaine
signe un contrat on parle d'un milliard
de francs avec une société basée en
suisse qui lui propose une nouvelle
méthode de recherche pétrolière
il s'agit grâce à l'électronique
d'analyser la composition géologique des
terrains survolé en avion et donc des
idées des forages coûteux à l'époque
valéry giscard d'estaing alors président
de la république et raymond barre
premier ministre aurait autorisé les
transferts de fonds nécessaires de plus
cette opération pouvant avoir des
conséquences intéressantes en matière de
défense nationale est classé secret
défense
soudain en 1979 la faire rebondir le
ministre de l'industrie de l'époque
andré giraud après avoir assisté à des
expérimentations négative décide
d'annuler toute l'opération
le presidents day albin chalandon
récupère une partie de l'argent versé
mais pas la totalité
et c'est là que tous les problèmes
commencent premièrement où est passé
l'argent nous rembourser deuxièmement la
cour des comptes engage une enquête et
remet les rapports aux autorités de
l'état or l'ancien premier président de
cette institution aurait détruit en 1982
l'original de ce rapport
troisièmement la direction des impôts
notifie à la société mère d'elf
aquitaine un redressement fiscal de 547
millions de francs pour dépenses
injustifiées
reste maintenant à connaître les
réactions à toute cette affaire
pas de déclarations ce soir chez rémo
bar niche et valéry giscard d'estaing
que l'entourage dit cependant très
serein monsieur giscard d'estaing serait
prêt à s'exprimer dans les prochains
jours
conseil des ministres ce matin le
traitement des fonctionnaires sera
revalorisé de 2% au 1er janvier
par ailleurs le ministre de l'économie
et des finances jacques delors a fait le
bilan des actions menées contre les
causes structurelles de l'inflation le
président mitterrand est intervenu à
cette occasion pour affirmer je cite les
termes du communiqué de l'elysée qu'il
n'est pas partisan de la politique des
indices mais de la réalité des fous et
des prix le président mitterrand a
également observé que les efforts
entrepris pour réduire les coûts
financiers des entreprises étaient
insuffisants tandis qu à l usine talbot
de poissy les syndicats continuent de
collecter les lettres de licenciement
sans se mettre d'accord sur leurs
destinations
le ministre de l'emploi jacques khalid a
déclaré aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale que les immigrés lice
ancien qui veulent retourner dans leur
pays pourront bénéficier d'une aide sans
toutefois en préciser la forme à côté de
l'automobile un autre secteur en crise
la sidérurgie et la mécanique lourde le
président du groupe creusot loire qui a
déjà annoncé en octobre 4000
suppressions d'emplois avec l'arrêt jour
d'hui que 6000 autres emplois était
fragile et que des licenciements devront
avoir lieu dans certaines activités du
groupe
un dossier de plus qui prouve à quel
point il est difficile dans la
conjoncture économique actuelle de
concilier les exigences de
l'assainissement industriel et de
l'emploi
jean claude renaud l'institut de la
statistique confirme que 1984 sera
l'année noire de l'emploi surtout dans
l'industrie il y à plus d'un mois
l'insee annoncé que cinq cent mille
emplois industriels seraient supprimés
entre 82 et 81 8
aujourd'hui il précise que 200 milles
disparaîtront entre joint 83 et juin 84
le secteur le plus atteint sera
l'automobile avec moins 100000 emplois
avant 88
tous les constructeurs seront touchés
avec peugeot talbot bien sûr où il faut
ajouter 4571 pré-retraite au 1905
licenciement de poissy chez citroën la
direction prépare 1500 suppressions
d'emplois mais la cfdt parle de 10000
même la régie renault se préparerait à
supprimer dix mille emplois en deux ans
voilà pourquoi l'attitude du
gouvernement dans le cas de talbot est
décisive car il devra se prononcer de la
même façon dans d'autres sectes dès le
mois de janvier dans les charbonnages
par exemple selon l'objectif de
production retenu 10000 à 20000 emplois
pourraient être supprimés
la direction des charbonnages en prévoit
d'ores et déjà 7 me
dès janvier aussi dans la construction
navale le gouvernement s'est engagé à ne
fermer aucun chantier mais il a demandé
au pdg de dire combien il faut supprimer
d'emplois sur les 22000 existant dans la
sidérurgie le plan acier brivois onze
mille suppressions d'emplois et pour
être vraiment compétitif
il en faudrait
à 35000 en deux ans la liste n'est pas
close puisque les experts prévoient
avant 88 60 7000 suppressions d'emplois
dans le textile habillement et 50000
dans la fonderie
c'est une véritable purge qui est
administrée à l'industrie mais c'est le
prix à payer pour que les différents
secteurs puisse moderniser et
réembaucher sur des bases solides à
partir de 85 86 revenons sur la sphère
des l'opération d'elf aquitaine et la
grave accusation de forfaiture lens est
donc cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale par le secrétaire d'état au
budget contre l'ancien premier président
de la cour des comptes bernard bec
nous sommes en effet en mesure de vous
diffuser maintenant la réponse de
monsieur bec une réponse qu'il n'a pas
voulu filmer parce que il a déclaré
quand 46 ans de fonction publique il
n'avait jamais jamais voulu être filmés
écoutons donc la réponse sonore de
monsieur bec recueillis par jean le
berre je répète que le rapport établi
non pas par la cour des comptes et selon
les procédures habituelles de la cour
mais par un magistrat de la cour
à la demande du premier ministre étaient
destinés à ce dernier et à lui seul je
résume le sentiment de faillir à la
promesse que je lui avais fait si ce
rapport avait pris quelques autres
directions que ce soit
je précise que ce rapport n'a à l'époque
été remis ni au ministre de l'industrie
ni au ministre de l'économie ni au
ministre du budget je précise encore que
le rapport ne contient aucune mise en
cause de l'honnêteté ou de
l'honorabilité ni des dirigeants de
l'erap ni de quelques personnalités
politiques que ce soit si j'ai un regret
à l'expriment a exprimé peut-être est-ce
là qu'est la véritable forfaiture
c'est qu'un tel dossier soit l'objet
d'une diffusion et d'un débat
public de cette nature c'était donc la
réponse de l'ancien président de la cour
des comptes bernard bec aux accusations
lancées cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale par le secrétaire d'état au
budget syndicats et patronat à nouveau
réunis cet après midi pour faire avancer
le dossier de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
cette réunion qui devait être la
dernière ne le sera pas le cnpf en effet
accepté de prolonger la convention
unedic jusqu'au 31 janvier prochain
les négociations vont donc pouvoir
continuer on évite ainsi l'intervention
de l'état que la cnpf ne souhaitait pas
la réunion jusqu'ici est positif dit on
le débat sur l'enseignement privé
continue après les propositions
présentées ce matin comme prévu au
conseil des ministres par alain savary
les réactions sont plutôt mitigés je
vous rappelle les grandes lignes de ses
propositions aux modifications de la
carte scolaire réglementation des
crédits consacrés à l'enseignement privé
financement des écoles privées par les
collectivités locales titularisation des
professeurs volontaires application de
la réforme des collèges à l'enseignement
privé chez les principaux protagonistes
se soit l'inquiétude a changé de camp le
cnal le comité national d'action laïque
manifeste contrairement au 16 octobre
dernier une certaine satisfaction quant
à l'enseignement catholique favorable il
ya deux mois aux propositions du
ministre il ne cache pas son inquiétude
la méthode adoptée par les éducations
peut porter ses fruits dans la mesure où
le ministre propose des avancées sur des
aspects qui sont significatifs
en fonction des conclusions auxquelles
on arrivera mais je note tout de suite
que on aurait dû et pu employer cette
méthode un an plus tôt dont elle a perdu
alors mieux vaut tard que jamais en ce
qui concerne le fond de toute façon on
va le retrouver et à savoir deux
réalités que toute une propagande décès
de maquiller premièrement la médiocre
qualité d'ensemble de l'enseignement
privé et deuxièmement les privilèges
tout à fait qui nourrit dont ils
bénéficient et que la droite politique
appelle des libertés tout à fait
indûment
je me réjouis très fort que dans des
délais brefs désormais le parlement ne
puisse être appelé à jouer son rôle qui
est essentiel car il va falloir
légiférer
cette nouvelle n'est elle nous inquiète
parce que nous refusons un des points
qui vous est proposé à négociations nous
l'avons déjà dit nous continuons à
refuser la titularisation des personnels
enseignants volontaires
il me semble que la perspective du
gouvernement demeure étrangement
semblables il s'agit de réduire
progressivement les différences entre
l'enseignement public et l'enseignement
privé
or ce qui est important c'est justement
que nous soyons différents cette
situation pourrait déboucher sur un
refus si les propositions qui nous sont
faites nous paraissent nous enfermer
dans une intégration progressive
le projet de loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur qui avait fait l'objet depuis
le début d'année de vives contestations
de la part des étudiants et les
enseignants ce projet de loi était
définitivement adopté la nuit dernière
par les députés
l'état de santé du président mitterrand
est tout à fait satisfaisant c'est ce
que déclare son médecin personnel dans
le bulletin de santé semestriels publiés
aujourd'hui par lise une mystérieuse
affaire rebondissent celle de la
disparition au même moment de deux
hommes d'affaires britanniques à paris
si l'un d'eux avait été retrouvée noyée
à brest le 2 décembre dernier
le second a été retrouvé hier soir noyer
lui aussi dans la seine près du bois de
boulogne
dominique tierces c'est à l'extrémité du
bois de boulogne aller du bord de l'eau
que le corps de john g a été repêché
hier soir
20 heures son corps ne portait aucune
trace de coups john g est mort noyé
emportant avec lui le secret de sa
disparition le 30 novembre dernier
john g 27 ans marié était expert
comptable dans une société anglaise
l'une des filiales de la société se
trouve à paris au numéro 19 de la rue
d'athènes il est venu trois fois par an
pour y vérifier les comptes comme
d'habitude il descendait dans cet hôtel
juste à côté
l'hôtel d'athènes c'est ici que le 30
novembre on l'a vu pour la dernière fois
john g qui occupait la chambre 21 était
sorti en fin d'après midi laissant ses
papiers et ses bagages dans sa chambre
il n'y reviendra jamais sa femme puis
ses parents s'inquiètent de sa
disparition
au cours d'un voyage express à paris ils
expliquent que leur fils était en bonne
santé qui ne lui connaissait pas
d'ennemis que toute cette affaire est
vraiment incompréhensible
une affaire qui ressemble étrangement à
celle de neil campbell 42 ans expert
économique dans une multinationale lui
aussi venait régulièrement en france la
multinationale qui l'emploie à une
filiale à clamart l'aï saisie neil
campbell était descendu à l'hôtel vernet
près de l'étoile le 1er décembre
neil campbell régler sa note d'hôtel et
sort faire quelques courses sur les
champs elysées lui aussi les sa valise
dans sa chambre le lendemain matin on le
retrouve noyé dans la rade du port de
brest
personne ne peut expliquer pour
l'instant pourquoi quand bella
précipitamment quitté paris ni alcan
belle john gran de citoyens britanniques
qui selon les familles ne se
connaissaient pas de mort bien
mystérieuse espionnage drogue
rien aujourd'hui ne confirme ses
hypothèses quatre arrestations à londres
après l'attentât contre le grand magasin
harrods quatre arrestations
aujourd'hui dans les milieux
sympathisants de
mouvement irlandais ira le fonctionnaire
bulgare incarcéré à rome dans le cadre
de l' enquête sur l'attentât contre le
pape et la filière bulgare
ce fonctionnaire est sorti de prison il
reste néanmoins assigné à résidence
le sport maintenant est d'abord le ski
coupe du monde descente dames a ans en
autriche
à la suite de sa double opération au
genou la saison dernière hanni wenzel
appréhendait la descente pourtant elle
s'est imposée aujourd'hui sur une piste
terriblement dangereuse
lionel chamoulaud une piste tellement
dangereuse qu'à l'entraînement la
hongroise à jack se dit qu'il une chute
est toujours dans le coma elle est
touché au crâne une piste glacée à la
limite du praticable pas vraiment
favorable aux françaises caroline attia
crédité du septième temps étaient
disqualifiés pour n'avoir pas franchi
correctement une porte direction
marie-luce valdo meilleure elle termine
4e à nivelles en planque dans le vent et
sous les eva lyster anizan la double
championne olympique c'est tout comme
celle là exclus des jeux courts
professionnalisme
alors elle se consacre à la coupe du
monde et aujourd'hui elle a vaincu son
angoisse à 27 ans et sa première grande
victoire en descente en 13 saisons
hanni wenzel ce qui pour le
liechtenstein les pronostics de pirate
bresse pour le quarté demain à vincennes
le 13 le 5 le 11 le 4 le 20/08 le 18 et
le 3 une tarte royal pour alléger cette
fin de journal ou plutôt un échange de
tarte cela s'est passé en grande
bretagne hier soir le héros
le prince charles d'angleterre philippe
harrouard c'était hier soir à manchester
le prince de galles comme chaque jour
inaugurait ici un centre culturel
lorsque tout à coup et oui cette jeune
comédienne lui réserva une surprise
culinaire pour ne pas être en reste son
altesse royale randy l'appareil et s'en
suivit un de ses sketchs qui firent le
succès de buster keaton
mais avec dans le rôle principal cette
fois le futur roi d'angleterre
un roi qui sait prendre les choses avec
humour sans perdre son sang froid
l'angleterre est rassuré le rêve d'
alain gillot-pétré une bataille de tarte
à la crème en garde à vue mais n'a pas
pas remplies de rigueur pour de ma peau
pour l'apparat pis pour les fêtes pour
les tartes à la crème parapublic heures
regarder pourquoi vous allez comprendre
tout de suite en voyant la photo
satellite regardent et voilà quand vous
voyez ça pour portes de la france vous
pouvez être sûr que demain il ne fera
pas beau voici la carte en milieu de
journée le dilemme nous dit la météo
nationale
de la pluie des nuages sur l'est et sur
le sud
ailleurs sur l'ouest quelques toutes
petites éclaircies mais un temps chargé
et cette zone depuis la vague basculer
dans la journée et passera elle aussi
d'ouest en est en cours de nuit dont
bref il ne fera pas beau neige à partir
de 15 100 m vent d'ouest assez fort en
manche côté température cela aux
températures quasiment printanières pour
le début de l'hiver de 9 degrés or de
pas moins de 8 degrés à lille à 17
degrés à bastia j'ai bien dit 17 moyenne
nationale de 13 degrés les conseils de
bison futé pour les départs de l'île de
france 2 de vendredi 23 décembre ne
partait pas de l'île de france entre 14h
et 18h ce sera bouché demain jeudi 22
décembre
les heurts du soleil levant
43 coucher 16h55 je vous rappelle que
c'est l'hiver même si ça ne se voit pas
et c'est la fête de saint françois
xavier à 23 heures tout sérillon vous
présentera notre dernière édition et
aura pour invité jean denis bredin
l'auteur d'un remarquable livre sur l'
affaire dreyfus qui a souhaité
rencontrer le cinéaste bertrand
tavernier demain 12h40 cinquantaine de
mini 18h30 c'est la vie j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20
heures
très bonne soirée